>>Young: Take a look at your graph--
>>In most classes variability
is the norm, not the exception.
>>We're going to be doing
an "I notice, I wonder".
>>Cantor: This teacher is aware that
these children learn at different paces
and so she is creating a mechanism to
see the developmental starting points
of a diverse group of kids
so that children can move
at different rates to
master the content.
>>Young: This classroom is
heterogeneously grouped.
This is a non-tracked class. Some kids
will be bypassing Algebra One next year
and going into an advanced class
and some kids will be
taking a pre-algebra class.
So, there's a wide range.
Today's graph had a lot of
information in it and, so,
it was perfect for an
"I notice, I wonder."
>>What is this graph telling us?
What do you notice in the graph?
Don't do the "wonders" yet, just your
"notices". Take about two minutes.
>>The "I notice, I wonder" helps
kids slow down and really focus
on what's in front of them.
They wrote about what they noticed and
then turned and talked to a neighbor
to enhance and to draw attention to
things that they maybe had missed.
>>Student: Renewable energy
aren't being used as much.
>>Student: Yeah. Seems to
be going down actually.
>>Cantor: The information
she is getting is
about the individual
variability in that classroom.
What the kids are getting is the
benefit of learning from each other.
>>Young: All right, let's get
a list of "I notice, I wonder".
>>Student: I noticed that petroleum
had a big jump in the 1900s.
>>Young: What's another "notice"?
>>Student: I notice this
is a monthly energy review.
>>Young: Oh, so, you're looking below
the graph as well as above the graph.
Awesome. All right, let's switch over to
the backside and I want your "wonders".
What do I wonder about this graph?
>>The "I wonder" is a great way for
me to see what they need to know.
>>So, what do you wonder? Oh, my
gosh, so much to wonder about.
>>Student: I wonder what
the other renewables are.
>>Young: It's also a time when
you can build confidence in kids.
>>Great question.
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Young: Yeah, I agree with you. Aidan?
>>Aidan: What is BTU?
>>Young: What is a BTU? Great question.
>>"I notice, I wonder" just
brings the conversation to a place
where all people can contribute.
It gives everyone a voice.
It allows kids to listen
to other people's ideas
before they do the analysis.
So, it's like a way to collect
information collaboratively,
but allowing time to think first.